in a quiet corner of the Belgian
countryside there is a place which seems
perfectly to capture the courage and the
sacrifice of so many that inescapably to
the hopelessness and the waste because
it was in these fields that the first
major battles of the Great War were
fought and it was in the same fields
four years later that the war stopped no
ground gained so many lives lost the
cemetery at since in four iam has been
here since the war it was the Germans
who created it but the farmer who owned
the land at the time had a demand the
Belgian landowner said to the Germans
you can have this land for free so long
as you treat the German and the British
dead the same so long as you commemorate
everybody equally and give them equal
burial rights and so they lie side by
side Germans British and Commonwealth
and among them the two men who for
Britain marked the beginning and the end
of the fighting this is John and John
was in the Middlesex regiment before the
First World War and he comes across with
the British Expeditionary Force and
they're searching for the Germans here
in Belgium near the Belgian town of Mons
and he goes out on his bicycle and they
spot the Germans and his mate goes back
to tell base but John is killed in
action and he becomes the very first
British combat casualty on the Western
Front dying on the 21st of August 1914
and we just walk this short distance
here between John and George and George
is the very last British soldier to die
in combat during the First World War
he's a barman from Leeds and he fights
throughout the First World War he was
here in 1914 perhaps he had met John but
he fights his way through the whole
First World War and then he's killed
just an hour and a half before the
minute hand ticks to 11 o'clock they
rest just yards apart the first and the
last and in between 1.1 million British
and Commonwealth soldiers two million
German soldiers will be Dees Meade they
all have names even if we don't know
some of them
and they all have stories john Parrs is
reflected in these words from his mother
Alice from the family home in Finchley
just weeks after the war started
she wrote to his regiment I have not
heard from him at all she said the War
Office can tell me nothing I should be
very grateful for any information as to
his whereabouts and so with this letter
from a mother about her boy
Alice Parr was to become the first to
grieve the first of so many to lose
their sons in this war it's hard not to
be moved by coming to a War Graves
Commission Cemetery it's hard to think
of anything but the sacrifices of these
men I recommend that everybody should
come and visit the Western Front there's
nothing like coming and seeing where
these men fought and died and now rest
forever what are the lessons to be
learned I think everybody has to take
their own lessons when they can will see
these places the Armistice was signed at
just after 5:00 a.m. on November the
11th it was to come into effect at 11
a.m. and yet still on that day alone
more than 10,000 men were killed or
wounded Mark Stone Sky News in Belgium